hoje vou falar com vocês hoje vou falar
com vocês sobre o só a calc
é o projeto consiste o estudo da
atividade solar através da fotografia
com materiais de baixo custo e tendo
como objetivo realizar também a
divulgação científica se tornando todo o
material disponível na internet em um
blog o porquê disso
a astronomia solar pode se pode dizer
que as tormentas olá é é a ciência mais
presente no nosso dia a dia porque tudo
com mais presente no nosso dia a dia mas
acaba sendo em comum pelo menos no
brasil pessoas acaba sendo um campo de
estudo muito distante
sendo que ele é de fácil acesso é de
possível fácil acesso
apesar de todos os fatores presentes não
mostram que eles não estaria aqui tem um
exemplo de 11 registros diário do
trabalho que é feito aqui do ano passado
esse aqui do início desse ano
alguns gráficos ali com com simples
contagem de manchas solares e outros os
sistemas de computação de valores por
hemisférios é mas o principal desse
projeto não é isso
o projeto tem como objetivo mostrar que
é possível se fazer ciência com poucos
recursos
a prática da ciência pode ser universal
apesar de hoje ela a pesquisa científica
ser muito mais realizado no meio
universitário
gostaria de dizer que esse trabalho é
feito em casa e tem isso aqui são alguns
registros com um equipamento especial do
clube de dormir dos cruz em campos
o equipamento do trabalho é contínuo que
o local que utiliza é esse aqui um
telescópio refrator dos modelos mais
simples e em questões de custo
extremamente barato
o equipamento que qualquer um pode
adquirir por exemplo esse telescópio que
eu paguei r$200 uma lente ocular um
filtro que foi uma doação e uma câmera
comum todo mundo tem caras um adaptador
para a câmera que foi utilizado foi
adquirido muito tempo depois e softwares
gratuitos
livre o que é possível fazer com isso
com o registro estudos manchas solares e
o registro ao longo de anos
você consegue compreender as compreender
questões climáticas da terra ou seja com
um estudo feito em casa com equipamentos
de baixíssimo custo
você pode começar a compreender a
começar a compreender mudanças
climáticas
coisas que ultimamente já era um tanto
polêmica e são gerenciadas por grandes
centros de pesquisa é e relação entre a
atividade solar e clima de um modo geral
a gente sabe muito pouca coisa mas pode
ser feito em casa e esse projeto caseiro
de modo simples tenham alcance
internacional
ou seja a ideia principal que quero
trazer que hoje é que esse projeto
também não busca só em fazer ciência e
divulgar mas também incentivar porque é
muito fácil fazer e é muito fácil também
até divulgar mas o que chega o que é o
mais difícil eo principal é cativar por
isso que um outro ponto principal desse
projeto é cativar as pessoas para que
elas possam fazer a ciência também
trazer de volta a idéia adiante a idéia
da antiguidade da ciência será universal
a ciência será algo pra todos
a ciência à investigação científica é da
natureza humana
uma criança com alguma medida que ela
vai crescendo a vai investigar no seu
meio vai colocando tudo na boca para
fazer experimentação literalmente e com
o tempo os adultos acabam podando essas
características e vai distanciando
indivíduo de sua natureza científica e
depois ela cresce e se vê no mundo em
que a ciência é algo possuído e gerido
por grandiosos
só que não precisa ser assim vocês aqui
que estão assistindo podem fazer algo do
tipo
e é esse tipo de mensagem que o projeto
busca levar é visitando escolas
universidades
esse evento que foi no colégio estadual
de uma cidade da região serrana
aqui na câmara de vereadores de outra
cidade com os planos da prefeitura
isso aqui em campos no ano retrasado no
ano passado
isso aqui uma universidade federal com
os estudantes de licenciaturas em ensino
médio e nas escolas visando uma escola
estadual da região em que é feita a
atividades práticas em sala de aula
aqui por exemplo sendo feita a projeção
solar ou seja o modo de observação do
sol e estudos o sol que você nem precisa
do filtro que é o filme acaba sendo mais
caro mas você pode fazer isso de forma
segura com não tenho esse gasto aqui no
início em abril desse ano aqui e o
trabalho esse trabalho chegou a ser
apresentado na quarta semana de
licenciaturas do ifs campus centro e foi
premiado como um dos dez melhores é tem
o apoio do clube luís cruz e do projeto
instrumental crb ix e eu quero voltar à
seguinte questão é esse projeto não
trabalha apenas com o estudo do sol
porque isso é um mais simples o mais
básico o e nenhuma na minha opinião
nenhuma pesquisa científica é totalmente
válida se não se constrói se não se
prepara o meio para que ela tenha
continuidade no futuro
o estudo do sol não pode ser totalmente
compreendido em escala de dias ou meses
mas sim décadas séculos então por isso
que é essencial semear essa idéia
existem outras pessoas no brasil
e no mundo que realizam esse trabalho
que eu faço depilação do sol
existem mas você não consegue ter um
fácil acesso a isso você não consegue
ter um conhecimento desse trabalho e é
contra isso que esse projeto busca
seguir tornar a ciência mais aberta não
capitalizada
ou seja para todos e o questionamento
que eu deixo eu sempre gosta de deixar
deixaram o questionamento no final
mostrando aqui tudo que eu já falei o
que eu faço e os objetivos lançar lançou
a seguinte pergunta por que não fazer
porque não fazer algo científico porque
o essencial
o mais importante não são os resultados
mas sim a prática você praticar a
ciência e é essa mensagem que eu gosto
mandar é transmitir sempre essa a
mensagem que quis transmitir aqui hoje é
um bom dia a todos
[Aplausos]